[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo hier sind Natalie Strauß und Mirko
Kasimir mit einer neuen Ausgabe von
Tatort Deutschland dem täglichen Podcast
und heute sprechen wir über letzte Worte
einige davon sind sehr berühmt geworden
so sagte Caesar auch du Brutus mein Sohn
und Goethe verlangte mehr Licht
Heinrich Heine dagegen war sich sicher
Gott wird mir vergeben das ist sein
Beruf die schönsten letzten Worte sind
wahrscheinlich die mit denen sterbende
ihre trauernden Angehörigen trösten ein
einfaches ich liebe dich oder vergiss
mich nicht aber lebe dein Leben so etwas
in der Art und ganz ehrlich dagegen
stinkt Goethe mit seinem mehr Licht
ziemlich ab heute geht es um die letzten
Worte von Lisette Andrea questa ihr
werdet sie in keiner Zitatensammlung
finden lisa war keine berühmte Dichterin
oder Politikerin Lisette war 19 als sie
starb ein lebensfroher Teenager aus
Kalifornien zu jung um sich über ein
Vermächtnis Gedanken zu machen und doch
waren ihre letzten Worte so
bedeutungsvoll wie sie nur sein konnten
der genaue Wortlaut ist nicht
überliefert aber sie enthielten zwei
Namen Daniel groß und Melissa Leonardo
sie nahm ihre Mörder
[Musik]
wie Tesla Road zwischen Livermore und
racy führt durch die spärlich mit
braunem Gras bewachsenen Hügel im
ella-mieder counti am östlichen Rand der
San Francisco Bay Area es ist der 19
februar 2018 kurz nach 2 Uhr nachts
Richard longhold und seine drei Kollegen
sind unterwegs zur Frühschicht bei UPS
als Richard vor ihnen am Straßenrand
etwas sieht es bewegt sich kriecht
langsam unendlich mühsam durch die
Dunkelheit
es glauben Sie ein verwundetes Tier zu
sehen doch schnell wird klar dass es ein
Mensch ist eine Frau schwer verletzt
Richard fährt den Wagen an die Seite die
vier steigen aus und rennen zu ihr die
junge Frau ist Blut überströmt das heißt
so sehr von Blut verklebt dass die
Haarfarbe gar nicht mehr zu erkennen ist
und im Hals klappt eine riesige Wunde
die vier Männer helfen ihr so gut ihr
Können wickeln Sie in eine Decke und
versuchen sie wach zu halten in einem
Interview erzählt Richard lautholt sie
sagte sie hat das Gefühl sie wird
sterben ich sagte nein das wirst du
nicht du wirst kämpfen du wirst dich
aufsetzen du legst dich nicht hin und du
wirst wieder gesund Richard und seine
Kollegen beten mit ihr und für sie
endlich treffen Polizei und
Rettungshubschrauber ein die verletzte
wird ins Krankenhaus geflogen sie hat
mehrere Stichverletzungen von einem
Messer und einem tiefen Schnitt im Hals
zwei Stunden später stirbt Lisette
Andrea Cresta doch vorher redet sie
ihren Eltern bleibt keine Zeit sich zu
verabschieden kein letztes ich liebe
euch stattdessen verrät sie die Namen
ihrer Mörder Daniel gross und Melissa
Leonardo sie hat wirklich gelitten sagt
Zarge und Break Kelly vom alamide
accounty Sheriffs Office aber sie blieb
anwesend und gab uns überzeugende
Informationen brauchst und Leonardo
werden noch am Morgen desselben Tages
verhaftet ihre Schuld steht außer
Zweifel und dennoch bleiben Fragen offen
wie genau ist die Tat abgelaufen wer von
den beiden hat sie tatsächlich getötet
und warum was muss Totschlag oder
Notwehr und wie beurteilt ein Gericht
die letzten Worte eines Sterbenden
Teenagers
Melissa Leonardo und Daniel gross kennen
sich schon lange und zwar sehr gut sie
arbeiten im selben Schnellrestaurant und
sind befreundet außerdem haben sie eine
Art Dreiecksbeziehung Melissa 26 Jahre
alt und der 19-Jährige Daniel sind
verlobt sie ist Schwanger er lebt in
ihrem Haus
gleichzeitig hat er eine Beziehung zu
Lisette und die zwei Frauen wissen dass
er mit ihnen beiden schläft also aus
einer Dreiecksbeziehung mit einer
Schwangeren Verlobten und einer deutlich
jüngeren geliebten kann man natürlich
ganz leichten Motiv basteln erst recht
wenn man weiß dass Melissa Leonardo als
sehr eifersüchtig gilt einmal soll sie
ihrem Freund in einem Laden angegriffen
haben als der einfach nur eine andere
Frau anschaute außerdem sammelt sie
besser laut der New gross ist folgendes
passiert in der Nacht von sie setzt tot
sind die drei gemeinsam im Auto
unterwegs sie rauchen Marihuana und
Daniel und Lisette haben Sex auf der
Rückbank
all das während Daniels Verlobte Melissa
den Wagen durch die Gegend fährt alles
einvernehmlich behauptet Daniel auch
dass er sie vor dem Sex mit einem gelben
Seil fesselt irgendwann halten sie an
die beiden Teenager steigen aus kurz
darauf greift die Set urplötzlich Daniel
an sie stößt ihren Ellenbogen in seiner
Rippen ihr wehrt sich verzweifelt rastet
schließlich aus und er sticht Lisette in
Notwehr genau schon klar Messer gegen
Ellbogen ganz klar Fall von Notwehr im
Gefängnis noch vor der
Gerichtsverhandlung gibt Daniel gross
den Sender Kay TV you ein Interview er
wusste nicht warum dieser ihn mit dem
Ellbogen angegriffen habe sie hätten
sich zu diesem Zeitpunkt nicht
gestritten und dann sah ja ausgerastet
es ist einfach so passiert sagt er und
schnipst mit den Fingern und echt jetzt
dieses Geräusch und diese Worte einfach
so ich finde das sowas von gruselig ein
Menschenleben mit einem Finger
ausgelöscht
die beiden lassen die sterbende Frau
einfach am Straßenrand zurück es dauert
Stunden bis die vier ups-fahrer sie
endlich finden Daniel gross und Melissa
Leonardo werden wegen Mordes angeklagt
Daniel gesteht weist aber jeden Vorsatz
von sich das alles sei nicht geplant
gewesen Melissa Leonardo plädiert auf
nicht schuldig
Daniels Geständnis scheint ihre Unschuld
zu bestätigen doch es gibt Zweifel und
zwar so richtig wir haben ja schon
gehört dass sie verdammt eifersüchtig
ist und Messer sammelt und in ihrem
letzten lebenstunden hat Lisa sie
wiederholt außerdem ist er noch die
Aussage der Mutter von Daniel Cross in
einem Interview mit ABC 7 erzählt Sie
Melissa Leonardo habe mit ihr über
Mordpläne gesprochen sie soll zu ihr
gesagt haben wir werden diese
fesseln und abstechen
vielleicht sollte ich ganz kurz erwähnen
dass wir gerade nicht Natalie zensiert
haben sondern dass da im Original
Interview ein Schimpfwort gepiepst wurde
später habe ihr Sohn sie beruhigt er
wolle das nicht und die Pläne sein vom
Tisch sie die Mutter aber ist dabei
bewenden lassen es kann natürlich auch
gut sein dass der jetzt Mutter da nicht
ganz sie Wahrheit sagt damit ihrem Sohn
nicht die ganze Schuld angelastet wird
aber da sind wir im Bereich der
Spekulation fakt ist jedenfalls das
Daniel zugestochen hat vor Gericht
stellt sich nun vor allem die Frage ob
es sich um einen Mord ersten oder
zweiten Grades handelt diese
Unterscheidung gibt es bei uns im
deutschen Strafrecht so nicht in
Kalifornien gilt jeder Mord als first
the green Mörder der mit Vorsatz und vor
bedacht gegangen wurde als secondy
gelten Morde ohne vor bedacht spontane
Morde wenn man so will im Fall einer
Verurteilung wegen Mord ersten Grades
droht Daniel groß eine Freiheitsstrafe
von 26 Jahren bis lebenslänglich für
Mord zweiten Grades liegt der Strafmaß
zwischen 16 Jahren und lebenslänglich
das Gericht muss ich noch mit einem
anderen Problem auseinandersetzen der
Anwalt von Melissa Leonardo beantragt
sie setzt letzte Worte in denen sie
seine Mandantin belasteten nicht vor
Gericht zuzulassen diese seien nur
Hörensagen komm on das ist richtig krass
mit ihrem letzten Atem verrät sie ihre
Mörder und das soll abgetan werden
ich meine ganz formal gesehen das ist
richtig die Zeugen können ja nichts über
den Mord an sich sagen sie können nur
wiedergeben was ihnen eine andere Person
darüber erzählt hat und dass diese
Person zufällig das Opfer selbst ist tut
erstmal gar nichts zur Sache aber das
wäre schon eine richtig krasse
Missachtung oder nicht zum Glück lehnt
der Richter den Antrag ab auch wenn es
vor mal schwierig ist besteht die
Möglichkeit eine solche sterbeerklärung
als Beweismittel in Strafprozessen
zuzulassen es gibt auch keine öffent
liche Informationen zum Ausgang des
Verfahrens man kann über Suchmaschinen
einen Strafmaß von 26 Jahren für Daniel
und 25 für Melissa finden aber
offizielle Angaben sind das erstmal
nicht sicher ist nur dass Daniel gross
und Melissa Leonardo viele viele Jahre
im Gefängnis sitzen werden dort haben
sie dann Zeit über ihre eigenen letzten
Worte nachzudenken die letzten Worte zu
diesem Fall war mit dem Vater von ihr
seid überlassen rayque
sie hat gewonnen weißt du ich meine ich
weiß dass sie gestorben ist aber als sie
ihr das angetan haben dachten sie sie
kommen damit durch und sie hat sie nicht
davonkommen lassen sie hat sich selbst
Frieden gebracht und sie hat mir und
meiner Familie Frieden gebracht
[Musik]
wow das war's für heute von uns für
unsere Geschichte haben wir auf Beiträge
der New York Post der Los Angeles Times
von CBS ABC 7 und katyvu zurückgegriffen
ich hoffe wir hören uns bald wieder bei
Tatort Deutschland eurem täglichen
Podcast mit Natalie Strauß